see for the Ant Hill analogy I don't
think people think about it carefully
enough because if the ants were able to
communicate to us there would be teams
of scientists there would be new stories
about look we can now communicate with
ants
further virtually every single species
on the planet has a professor whose sole
job it is to study it it's difficult to
find
a life form that we're not interested in
and then third we are concerned with
species preservation
so if the ants were going to war with
gorillas and one of them were going to
be wiped out somehow we would care about
that like we already care about that and
there are some people who care about
Extinction so there's both sides
so I don't see this dispassionate
assessment because it's an ant hill and
we're so much more advanced as holding
up to indicate that we don't
want to intervene or communicate back
because if we could that would be
firstly we're teaching gorillas to try
and communicate to them same with
parrots and we're super excited when
they could say a syllable or a string
together a verb and an adjective and
it's like a revolutionary and Chomsky
gets involved yeah you you bring up a
great you bring up a great rebuttal the
only reason I would I would push back is
not every human being studies you're
talking about a very small percentage of
humans that that make that study and
that care
um I'm one of those that care right so I
love I'm an animal geek I love that I
love that kind of stuff but sadly
Humanity doesn't so the reason I bring
up the analogy is talking about life
forms as a whole uh here on Earth
Humanity as a whole what's the
percentage that cares broaden that to a
wider scope in the universe uh to find a
full civilization that would again want
to come here and speak to us and and
save us
um that to me is more of the point that
it would be a much smaller if if a
percentage point at all but on top of
all that using what uh rebuttal you just
brought up which was great
um
we want to save that life form because
all we know is one planet and that's it
right so so life is precious to us as it
and I agree with that right like I
believe life is precious but if if then
the universe and Cosmos is teeming with
life would another Advanced civilization
have that same appreciation and that
same care to go okay people of Earth or
creatures of Earth uh you know we we
don't want you to be extinct we want to
we want to coddle you I want to believe
that that's true because I'm the type
that in my backyard I will save a
hummingbird in my pool which there's
pictures I we do that all the time me
and my kids we'll say if hummingbirds
we'll say so we do that right but it's
because we have that appreciation for
life would a civilization millions of
years ahead of us in a cosmos teeming
with Life Care
and and that's that's I think the bigger
question here is that we want to think
they would because of humanity and where
we are in the infant stages that we are
but the reality is
it could be a machine that we run into
when we talk about an extraterrestrial
and and that brings up this whole other
debate uh wherein we we are operating
off the assumption that we are going to
run in to a biological creature of some
kind but that unanswered question is
when that happens if it hasn't already
will it be biological at all and then
that brings up a whole other slew of
questions so
I get your your point absolutely but for
me I remove myself as much as I can from
humanity and try and look at it as a
bigger picture and that's where I feel
the the Ant Hill analogy then comes into
play
yeah I see that I'll say some thoughts
that occur to me
number one is that if they're
sufficiently Advanced then they would
have something like Auto GPT so right
now we have AIS and they can run
automatically without our intervention
so it could be that even though the
average person doesn't care about a
particular animal like you mentioned
there's a subset of people who care
about a particular animal even though
that's the case it could just be it runs
automatically so it doesn't matter that
all of us as a whole aren't it could be
that you're sending out probes
automatically secondly this is something
I think about we tend to think that
what's valuable is what's rare it's like
diamonds and gold but it may be the case
that we have that backward and that
that's based in something like
materialism and that what may be the
most valuable is what's the most
abundant and that is to say like our
Consciousness or our meaning or
significance
it's a difficult concept to parse out
because we tend to make an equivalence
between what's valuable and what's rare
and what's uncommon I don't see it as
being completely obvious that what's
precious is what's most rare it may be
the opposite what's precious is what's
most common
yeah and you bring up an interesting I'm
not sure if this will connect to your
thought at all but you bring up an
interesting point about the gold and and
the you know the precious metals that
are precious to us and and therefore
valuable
if we were able to go out those precious
metals to us humans is completely
abundant like there's that one I forget
exactly the value of the the comment
that they said is is worth like
quintillions of dollars uh and that you
know the idea is that if you go out and
actually can rope it and bring it in and
you can start mining it and so on and so
forth it brings up I guess an
interesting concept that what and which
kind of plays into my point earlier is
that what is essentially rare to us
that we we value it more gold is much
more valuable than dirt you know because
it's it's much it's much more precious
to us and so on and so forth and and
therefore we coddle that and we we we we
hold on to it it's got value it grows in
value but using gold as the example in
the cosmos that's one of those precious
metals that if you rope one of those
comets you completely crash the gold
market here uh because you you are just
overflowing with it and it's not
precious anymore it's just a metal it's
just dirt you know it's not worth
anything uh that I think plays into what
I was saying earlier where here on Earth
Humanity values what it does because
we're small and that's all we know but
once that broadens to literally a cosmic
scale those values change both monetary
values but also what's here and what's
here in our mind in our heart so it it
it's a mind-blowing topic because you
can go so many different ways and like
you said does the abundance create value
I'm not sure maybe maybe with a higher
intelligence that would come into play
but sadly for Humanity as you and I chat
right now that's not that's not the case
and and that's that's how we have to at
this point think about how it might be
out there just because we don't know
where we're going to be in a thousand
years
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy